all right frankie
frankie where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
originally um born in berkeley
california san francisco
and tell me about your family growing up
you had both your parents um my mom uh
was uh alcoholic dad was a heroin addict
couldn't take care of me really uh
so i really didn't know them at all
uh
they he drove me down to my aunt's house
or who's his sister and she basically
took me in when i was six months of age
and i grew up in her household and down
in north hollywood
and
better for me because i could only
imagine how my life would have been
over with my mom and dad
dad's no longer alive he owe deed
mom's still alive in a halfway house
um don't talk to her
and i only met my dad once when i was
six years old i met him down at the
greyhound over in santa monica and uh
yeah let's just say i called him ray not
a dad
well how was your childhood with your
aunt oh it was great i had a great
childhood um
happy uh
took me to griffith park all the time
birthdays always had a birthday um
never abused me
she never
she never did drugs really uh maybe
smoked a little pot but that's about it
as i found out later but that's great
that's about it uh she's a good she's a
good mom to me like i call her mom she's
she's great she's an angel yeah
but you still got
attracted to drugs somehow yes i guess
that uh hidden underneath this skin i
have like uh
um
i think uh my personality is a
what do i want to call it it's like a a
addictive personality
and i guess my mom says that that's in
my genetics uh because of my dad and mom
um how they were so yeah it's sort of
funny how i ended up doing heroin and my
dad was a heroin addict so
so
your drug is heroin or fentanyl now i'm
doing fentanyl now
and that's because
heroin i would shoot up i shot up heroin
for 13 years religiously
i
shot up because smoking wouldn't take me
where i wanted to go which was a nod
asleep away from all the problems in my
head and stuff
and when i found fentanyl like at like
you know going to
you know different places in the city
and stuff people started busting up
fentanyl and
i take one hit and i'm out you know and
that's exactly where i wanted to go and
i realized that fentanyl took me there
smoking it and i hate smoking but
i don't shoot it because it's just way
too strong and um i smoke fentanyl now
because it took me it took me where i
wanted to be at on that first hit didn't
have to waste money like with heroin
trying to dip and dab find which one was
better or whatever
but i loved heroin
so
and fentanyl
i love fentanyl now like i use it every
day
i have a lot of friends that have died
from it passed away
and um
i don't know
i don't want to die but i just don't
know why i'm still alive so you say you
love it i mean a lot of the fentanyl
addicts i've talked to
i say they just need it to feel well
but do you actually love it
i love it i think i do love it you know
in a matter because uh
it takes me away from all the stuff in
my head um like i got some dark like
some
underlying stuff that uh
like okay i use i basically use now uh
like three years ago i had a daughter um
she was born uh with methadone in her
system because at the time me and my
baby mama
haley
um were on that got on methadone so uh
we found out she was pregnant um
because we were trying to quit uh she
wanted to we took her down to the doctor
to lower her dose and the doctor
wouldn't do it because her being
pregnant was a liability he said the
baby could die from not like you know
what i mean so basically our daughter
zoe was born
with 70 like she was on 70 milligrams
when uh she was born so
when she was born she was withdrawing
really hard i would when i would hold
her i could feel her like bodies like
kicking struggling to just get a
comfortable spot and it
was a lot to do with
my mental state and it was hard to watch
and she said see such a little baby go
through it
and then 28 days later she i got a call
from dcsf
that she had passed away at three in the
morning
they said it was sids but
i i think it was due to them releasing
her too early from the hospital
and uh her maybe her heart stressing out
and she was put with a foster mom who
didn't uh know anything about
addiction or withdrawals or anything so
i think that my daughter was set up for
failure in a way sorry and
that that hurt a lot um
i was happy to be a dad and and it
didn't get to happen i
i have a lot of
resentment
towards religion i'm not
really based upon religion right now i
i don't know how to base it on religion
it's not based on religion it's based on
just my my hurt so when i do fentanyl
i take a hit and all that stuff just
goes away and when i fall asleep it just
stops my brain from
like just cycling around what would
happen all the events that bother me in
my life and stuff and i just get away
from it for that session of smoking and
stuff is the the biggest pain that
you're running from with your daughter
that you lost or is there other uh
granted i have i'm blessed to have a
daughter
today my baby mama haley's made an
agreement that uh we were together for
13 years
and after our baby passing away she uh
we didn't she didn't want to be together
anymore because all she said i reminded
her it just reminded her reminded her of
everything that happened between us
so she made me a deal um
i wanted to kill myself like i was angry
and
she told me if she gave bless me with
another baby uh would i be able to let
her go
and
i said yeah i said if that's what you
want i said yeah
so she had another we had another
daughter and the day that
our daughter
autumn her name's autumn we named her
adam uh when she was born and she got
released from the hospital that was the
last time i saw haley uh she she split
and took off after the our daughter got
released from the hospital and
i haven't seen her uh still since she
was released till this day
and today she's in a new mexico prison
in ensenada is that right yeah for two
years
well and your daughter is where uh she's
at home with my mom uh her grandma and
she's healthy and happy and she loves
your dad very much your aunt actually
yeah my aunt yeah so yeah basically you
know what i mean like i call her mom
though so yeah yeah but yeah she's at
her grandma's you know
and you're staying where now
um i
am i was on the streets i've been
okay i went to this i got on the streets
because i was living at home on mom uh
but when my daughter was born dcsf would
not let her come over
like she would not be released to my
grandmother unless i wasn't living in
the house anymore because of my drug
addiction
so basically when i heard that i i said
here i'm gonna move out so that day when
i found out about it i moved out to the
streets and that was uh
i was like uh probably like three like
three and a half years ago so i've been
on the streets for about almost four
years
and um
you look very clean and put together for
somebody who's on the streets yeah i
like uh the one thing i do and i was
raised up with is good hygiene and
taking care of yourself uh but basically
i have a tiny home now
i was uh blessed with a tiny home and
um i've been in there for about two
months now these are the new
small these are
this is a new a new thing they have for
homelessness the government yeah uh
there's a big homeless problem out here
in california so they're basically have
these encampments where they have like
these little tiny homes they're like
sheds pretty much you can imagine a shed
in the backyard and that's basically
what it is and yeah how many are they
roughly huh how big are they
they're as big as like uh one car garage
uh if you know what i'm talking about
it's like
like probably from that cone to that
trash can or no a little small from that
line to that trash can and
they expect two people to live in there
but i don't think that's i don't think
it's gonna be take over too well as you
know so hopefully i'm in there by myself
right now so that's cool yeah but i love
it and they have showers they have
everything um you could even do drugs on
the uh showers are not in your in your
no they're not there and there's no
kitchen either um but they serve hot
food three times a day breakfast lunch
and dinner showers they have another
like mobile uh unit and it says like
four showers to each one so we basically
just share showers but some of these
people don't have
like good hygiene like some other people
would so they're based they're basically
dirty as [ __ ] sometimes and it's hard to
find it when it's not that dirty
but yeah and basically tiny homes gives
a place for us to like live and not be
on the streets and safely do our drugs
and
hopefully
get well enough to get back on our feet
and get a job maybe i don't know or
something you know do you see yourself
getting clean one day
um
that's hard to say um yeah definitely i
i mean i could say it but uh
i don't know if it will happen
i don't i don't know
basically i i got a lot of stuff in my
head that when i realized i'm when i'm
withdrawing and i'm coming down
all this stuff from when my daughter zoe
passed away just hits me in my head it's
it's just like and it makes me um very
it makes me very sad and i i i crumble i
i'm handicapped at that point until i
get my fix and then it all goes away
again you know and that's not a good
thing but
that's how i work with i deal with it
right now you know so
how do you support yourself now
um
i i'm a booster um
i go to i don't like i don't steal from
people i don't steal from other
people on the streets or anybody else i
i don't like to make it personal like
that so i go to the corporations and i
steal from them because they're the ones
that
i think don't appreciate or deserve our
business um
like department stores and things like
that yeah home depot cbs's walgreens i
take hygiene
um
any kind of order that someone needs
clothing i will go to ross marshalls
and i'll just rack it up that's what we
call it racking it up and then you'll
take it to a fence a fence yeah a vendor
meaning macarthur park originally where
i started doing that at but i started
getting smart and i networked
around north hollywood and i went to all
these food trucks and like the vent the
pisces that sell the food out by the
metro i i went up to them and they
said yeah yeah bring your stuff over
here so i started doing it closer to
home too i got a lot of vendors now that
take my stuff and
how does this lifestyle affect you
emotionally
lifestyle is not a lifestyle this
lifestyle is not life it's um
i'm stuck in a
a never-ending cycle of doing the same
thing every day
and i think the drugs are there just to
help us uh forget about that part of it
and um
basically we go out and we boost not to
only have money but
just to have something to do i guess
because i don't know know how i mean
there's plenty of other ways to make
money but that's just the easiest way
to get it done i'm risking my freedom
every time i do it too so yeah have you
been arrested
i've been arrested a few times before
i've never been to prison but i've been
to county and tell you that's not fun uh
at all everybody knows that um
but i have not been caught boosting you
i've actually uh
got some skills in that i guess
not been caught yet you've been to lake
county jail uh yeah a few times the
towers as they call them what is that
like
that sucks man that's that just puts you
and your um back in your body
you don't
once you get sobered up you're just in
your own skin and that's the hardest
part about it i think
it's scary to some people that if you're
not used to
being around people or on the streets i
think that it's it's a scary place it's
a dirty place it's very dirty
and it's not fun at all it's a
it's very um
the the guards the jail is it tells you
what to do you don't do what you want to
do they tell you how when you're gonna
eat when you're gonna sleep when you're
gonna shower if if you can do this if
you can do that if or you're not gonna
do that you know what i mean
it's not a good place to be is it
dangerous as well
very dangerous very dangerous um
stabbings things that you
wouldn't think that is a big deal out on
the streets in there
it's ten times a problem
basically you don't talk to other races
you stay with your race you don't do
business with other races
and respect is a big thing in there too
if you don't have respect you don't got
anything at all basically
so
and your word is a big thing in there
too
the the lives the crime the crime
lifestyle you know
yeah jail is not something that you want
to look forward to doing
so do you have friends
huh do you have friends i have plenty of
friends um oh well actually
i've learned to call them acquaintances
not friends because friends um are hard
to come by in this lifestyle i've have
very few friends i have probably maybe
[Music]
three three good friends that i can call
friends and not acquaintances but most
people don't are not around too long you
know you just a lot of pastor buyers a
lot of people that like to
deceive you and make you think that
they're your friend and then they snake
in and and then once they get what they
want from you they're gone vanished not
even a higher goodbye or whatever
they're just there until they can take
what they want from you and then or use
you for what they need you for and then
that's it
it's very disposable friendship out here
in the streets
yeah do you deal with emotion that's
like
depression or anxiety or anger things
like that
yeah um
i have a lot of anger um depression yeah
i'm as i grow older i realize that um
i regret my my drug use um
i regret addiction i don't know how to
do you regret addiction because that's
not something i chose um
[Music]
it's very sad as i grow older um
my family members are dying um getting
older and
i see i'm seeing my daughter grow up and
sometimes i
i get jealous uh
just wish that i can
go back and be like be young as her
again you know what i mean and um
i'm learning that life is a very sad and
very
it's a [ __ ] up way of uh existence i
think i think i i used to think i used
to hate i don't mean to bring up god but
i hate god in a way because
he's such a
sick person to
to bless us with life that needs to be
balanced with something called death and
um
her we're the weakest things on this
planet everything around us is stronger
than we are we crumble we break we're
like glass and
sometimes and a lot of times it's not
fair what what happens to us and um
life i wish sometimes i never even had
you know
do you feel like you were
given this genetic
tendency to to want to
use drugs
that's the only thing that um you have
an addictive personality so it's like
you're predisposed to become an addict
almost yeah exactly it sets you up for
it yeah
is that what you're angry at god is
maybe about
yeah um it is i'm angry that he can
bless or maybe he's not even maybe he
doesn't even have anything to do with
any of this you know that's just what
they say god god is something
a bible was written by a man you know
what i mean time is man-made everything
is man-made
uh god i have never seen i have never i
don't know if there is a god and i don't
deny that there is but i'm just saying
i've never seen it i never felt his
presence i've never
maybe i have been blessed i know i've
been blessed but was it his blessing or
was it just
my doing because
you know i made it and that's what i had
at baby do you feel guilt or shame about
being a drug addict yeah a lot uh for my
daughter's sake you know um
i see her every day but i'm not around
like a father should be uh she she loves
me to death and i
she she yearns for my presence more and
as that time goes on i realize that
i do care
about what she wants and i'm trying to
detach myself a little slowly from the
drugs more and staying at my mom's my
daughter and it's very hard to do
addiction is real addiction is
physically
painful and it's mentally discouraging
somebody who maybe doesn't know that
much about addiction might say why don't
you just put on the drug and go back to
your daughter
yeah if it was that easy um
i wouldn't be here right now
yeah you know it's not just like that
it's uh it's not possible to just walk
away it is no no mine is a powerful
thing if you really wanted to you could
i just think the withdrawals my
withdrawals from uh being addicted so
long or rare like i gotta get
hospitalized sometimes due to my uh
withdrawals because uh
i i my body is just my immune system
goes too down and i get very i'm
vulnerable to getting sick really bad
and just health problems i don't really
have until i get
until i try to get clean that's when
everything starts to pop up
so it basically just hides it underneath
everything until you decide that you
don't want to do it anymore it's
interesting to me in the years i've been
doing this even in the coldest weather
when you think everyone living on the
streets especially would be sick with
flus and colds and all kinds of other
illnesses nobody is getting sick
you know what uh we've been exposed to
everything we are uh stronger than most
people that live inside homes and live
are blessed to live inside homes and
have housing and roofs over their head
we have been exposed to everything that
you could think of we're stronger our
immune systems i think are stronger but
that's only with drugs
with drugs we're probably weaker than
most people without drugs without drugs
yeah without yeah nobody was even
catching covet when covert was at its
height maybe i have caught covered i was
very sick at the very beginning of it
but i got tested i've been tested more
than a few times and i i've never
uh they never said positive it's always
been negative but i think at the very
beginning i got the covet and my body
learned to adapt to it and
i'm uh like immune to it now i think
what stresses you out now what do you
worry about right now
um what are you afraid of in life
i'm afraid that um
i'm never gonna
be able to
show my mom that i understand and that i
appreciate her for everything that she
has done for me and my daughter and i
feel that
our relationship is like we're not the
best of friends we argue a lot but we
love each other and
i just feel like i'm not there's not
enough time to
to to show her um
my love and and
and
how much i do care about her
i try trust me i try but
to her it's just not enough
but yeah that's my deepest regret do you
think the uh
the biggest hurdle
as a fentanyl addict is the physical
addiction or is it
somehow psychologically you don't feel
like you deserve a better life or or all
that not at all i feel like
trauma that you're dealing with with
losing your daughter i think it's about
losing my daughter um physical addiction
is there
when it all comes down to the bottom
line is it's the physical withdrawal
that's what make
breaks me right there it's like when i
start feeling sick [ __ ] it i [ __ ]
everything i need to fix and then i'll
deal with that you know what i mean
whatever it is yeah it's the withdrawals
yeah
and
the pain is there too with my daughter
passing my first daughter but um i think
it's the withdrawals that start making
me notice that that
pain in me you know
living this life for as many years as
you have
do you think it's changed you
a lot it's changed me a lot um
i'm i'm social i socialize a lot but i
don't
socialize in the way of how
people with jobs and people with houses
do um it's a different kind of
socializing um
i shut away when things get real and
things get hard i
i shut down i
keep to myself and i try to like close
my eyes or or sleep and and hope it all
just goes away and it never does it's
always just right there
to confront you when you're
out of your stoop out of your
high
what do you wish
people that
are not involved in addiction and
homelessness
what do you wish they knew or understood
about addiction
i wish they understood that um
some people just um
have more problems than others and that
some people have different kind of genes
and and and addictiveness levels
and i wish they understood that not all
of us
chose this life or drugs
or um i just wish they understood that
we're human beings too
and um probably not the greatest human
beings but um
who's to say that they're any better
than us who don't use drugs um i just
wish they understood that we are human
beings and that
that that they can learn a lot from us
and um
and understood that drugs
is is not something that we made the
government made drugs and i think that
we were set up for failure
and as for which they understood all
that part of it
and if i could drop the drugs and i wish
they understood that if i could drop the
drugs without looking back and
not feeling withdrawal that i would i
would in a
second that's what i wish they
understood and i would and i hope they
unders
stood i wish they understood that
um
that drugs are not all bad
drugs are not all bad just
just uh the image that the government
and the media puts on it is is what they
want you to see and that's not
everything that there is to it you know
that's all that i wish they understood
[Music]
have you seen a therapist about your
heart about losing your daughter have
you ever talked to a therapist about
that
yeah i have and um
didn't work out great um
you can't
you can't
get like there's no label what the kind
of doctor you get for these kind of
things you know um there's been people
on the streets that have helped me out
more with that um through talking and
stuff other than a doctor that just
doesn't even listen sometimes they're
just basically writing their notebook uh
it's the it's the the eye to eye that
like i feel like i'm not they're not
connecting to me they're not feeling my
what i'm really saying and how real it
because it's not them they don't
understand
the realness to it unless it would
happen to them or they
you can say all day day that uh oh
that's never gonna happen to me but that
was me when i found out my daughter died
that that was me that day i was that
person that it happened to you and i
thought it would never happen to me and
therapists just uh doctors there's no
way of
diagnosing or helping this kind of thing
i think that this thing is just takes
time a lot of time and
a lot of hurt a lot of pain and maybe
i'm going through this because i need to
i don't know i don't know
but it happened you know
and i wish that it didn't
yeah
frankie what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
uh holy
i'm 34 years old
yeah my birthday is june 30th 1987 and
um what i have learned
is to always put your best foot forward
out here in these streets and anywhere
you go
because in a less than a second
you can have your life taken from you
and um
just always just treat people
don't treat people like animals even
though they act like animals they're not
animals
and i'm learning more that um
there's more to life
than uh
this misery and i just haven't found it
my way into it yet
and um that's what i've learned
all right frankie thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you appreciate
the opportunity thank you
you